[Music]
bts lit
up the grammy awards like dynamite on
sunday night
and we're not mad about it
the k-pop group who was nominated for
best pop duo
or group performance rocked their single
toward the end of the show
[Music]
they even recreated the grammy's red
carpet for their set which really took
place in korea
[Music]
and although the band didn't take home a
grammy on sunday night
they're still coming off a big awards
weekend taking home three kids choice
awards on saturday
for favorite song favorite music group
and
favorite global music star oh what a
surprise
thank you kids juice wars and army for
giving us all these amazing awards
you've shown such great love to our song
dynamite
hello is this army we love you
you guys are the best keeping amazing
dynamite which was released in august
was bts's first song completely in
english
and eventually rose to number one on the
billboard hot 100 for four weeks
straight
an accomplishment they credit to their
fans the bts
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
you